After explaining definitions from his book
‘Elements’, Euclid went on to explain
some AXIOMS that would help in understanding
geometry better.
What are axioms, you may ask?
The general meaning of an axiom is a statement
that is universally true and
needs NO proof. For example, we all know that
most humans have one brain!
We just know its true and must be accepted!
Similarly, Euclid assumed that some properties
were true and did not have to
be proved. He called these truths as ‘AXIOMS’.
These axioms are not restricted
to geometry, and can be applicable throughout
mathematics. They will help us
to prove and understand complex geometry in
the upcoming lessons.
In this lesson, we will study some of his
axioms. The first axiom is:
“Things which are equal to the same thing
are equal to one another.”
What does this mean?
Let’s understand with an example. Suppose
Bob and Rob go to a store and
both of them have five rupees. Bob buys a
pen for five rupees and for the same
price, Rob buys two candies. This means that
the cost of ONE pen is equal to
the cost of TWO candies!
So if later Rob wants to trade his candies
for Bob’s pen, he would have to give
two candies to Bob. This means the VALUE of
ONE pen is equal to the VALUE of
TWO candies!
In mathematical sense, if a quantity ‘A’
is equal to ‘B’ and ‘B’ is equal to
‘C’,
then ‘A’ is equal to ‘C’.
a=b and b=c then a=c
The second axiom states that: “If equals
are added to equals, then wholes are
equal”.
To understand this axiom in a simpler way,
imagine if for FIVE rupees you get
TWO candies and for SEVEN rupees you get ONE
pen. So if you add them
together, you will see that for a total of
TWELVE rupees you will get TWO
candies and ONE pen!
In the mathematical sense, let’s say a quantity
‘A’ is equal to ‘C’ and quantity
‘B’ is equal to ‘D’. Then ‘A’
plus ‘B’ will be equal to ‘C’ plus
‘D’.
a =c and b=d  a+b = c+d
The third axiom says that: “If equals are
subtracted from equals, then the
remainders are equal”
Similar to the second axiom, if a quantity
‘A’ is equal to ‘C’ and quantity ‘B’
is
equal to ‘D’, then ‘A’ minus ‘B’
will be equal to ‘C’ minus ‘D’
a = c and b = d  a-b = c-d
We will explain the remaining 4 axioms in
the next part of the video!